[Musique]
bon anniversaire mon bel amour se s'est
mal passé entre nous et je te demande
pardon je sais qu'un simple anniversaire
surprise ne pourra pas tout arranger je
t'aime de tout mon coeur
jusqu'à ce que la mort nous sépare
[Musique]
c'est moi j'aurai je suis étonné que tu
sois arriver aussi loin
mais j'ai une dernière surprise
bon anniversaire mon bel amour
[Musique]
on reste ici jusqu'à ce qu'on ouvre le
corps deux cent mille dollars en
diamants on partage les diamants ok
deux personnes connaissent la
combinaison du coffre et une d'elles un
trou dans la tête
trouve la fille et pourrait être à des
kilomètres d'ici
elle est encore dans la maison
c'était lent servira à rien
tu veux crier à pleins poumons
l'histoire est vraie
bon anniversaire
un couple si parfait
je vais me libérer toi même s'il faut
que ce soit la dernière chose que je
fais